je veux juste parler à monsieur la
décennie qui florian pardon mais vous
vous avez un sérieux sur ce que vous
dites parce que vous prenez un peu les
français pour des cons quand même penser
et vous pensez que les gens après ce qui
est resté courtois mais je suis content
mais à un moment donné à un moment donné
c'est vrai il dit que les français ont
besoin de voir emmanuel macron comme il
est mais est ce que vous pensez
sérieusement il ya un français sur terre
qui pensent qu emmanuel macron il est
comme ça il est cool gentil il rigole
machin et puis c'est le président ce que
vous en savez le président de la
république syrie ont le président la
république aujourd'hui vous pensez pas
qu'il a autre chose à gérer lors d'une
crise énorme vous pensez qu'il a besoin
de se mettre en scène de cette énième
essai il venu répondez oui mais je ne
vais pas lui répondre parce que je n'ai
pas à lui répondre au fond sa réaction
alors elle est intéressant de sa
réaction parce qu'elle marque le clivage
générationnel
on veut pas parler aux boomers réac qui
ne comprend pas le monde dans lequel on
vit et qu'il en soit ce que l on veut
ici le nom séduction de la jeune âge je
ne vous ai pas coupé je crois donc à
lorient alésia et si vous avez envie d
avoir un minimum de respect de l'autre
la bonne chose c'est que tu as quatre
soldats ici ça méritait elle les
difficultés ici essayer de séduire la
jeunesse et donc il y a évidemment un
clivage générationnel entre ceux qui ne
comprennent même pas les codes qui
réside sur youtube ça sera donc
évidemment choqués par ce qui s'y passe
parce que le vieux qui regarde la vidéo
youtube il comprend pas ce qui s'y dit
comprends pas comment ça fonctionne
habituellement parce qu'il n'a pas
regardé les vidéos avant les gens
d'autres influences heures etc
mais c'est évidemment le clivage qui
ressort ici dans l'opinion mais on peut
pas regretter que des millions de jeunes
s'engagent positivement sur la vidéo du
président du république vous pensez
qu'ils vont s'engager positivement même
en ayant tous les je crois que